a menos de dos semanas de las elecciones
presidenciales los peruanos fueron
testigos de un atentado a sangre fría en
el que perdieron la vida menores de edad
que hemos visto como un grupo de
terroristas asesinados cobardemente
cobardemente
seis personas algunos de los fallecidos
son niños y niñas una niña de un niño de
tres años y dos adolescentes
esto no quedará impune
la masacre ocurrió el pasado domingo en
un bar de una aldea ubicada en la
principal zona de producción de cocaína
de perú y que es centro de la actividad
de los remanentes de la guerrilla
sendero luminoso según la policía actúan
como socios y guardaespaldas de
narcotraficantes es a ellos que el
ejército peruano responsabiliza del
ataque y esta organización ha perpetrado
muchas emboscadas a policías y militares
no desde si tiene experiencia de guerra
armada que le heredaron de los 80 y 90
de la era en que estuvieron en sendero
pero hoy definitivamente lo podríamos
llamar una organización armada desde el
narcotráfico en el lugar de la matanza
también fueron encontrados panfletos que
alentaban a los peruanos a abstenerse de
votar en las elecciones presidenciales
del próximo 6 de junio en las que se
enfrentan el socialista pedro castillo
contra la conservadora keiko fujimori
hija del ex presidente alberto fujimori
quien permanece en prisión en las
décadas de 1980 y 1990 pero sufrió un
prolongado conflicto
la guerrilla sendero luminoso y las
fuerzas gubernamentales una lucha que
provocó la muerte de 69 mil personas
según cifras oficiales una facción
disidente del grupo original todavía
está activa en la selva peruana donde se
denominan el militarizado partido
comunista del perú